fun fact
this shirt is not wet
i i don't know what happened but i love
this shirt so i'm wearing it anyway
citizens of the reject nation we got
ourselves the third episode of lord of
the rings john how are you i am good how
are you good almost 24 hours awake and
i'm ready to
receive this episode today for a thick
boy uh there's some other things i've
been doing outside of this channel that
have been keeping me very very busy but
i'm excited it's lord of the rings guys
and those first two episodes have gone
over universally
one hundred percent ever everyone's it
so yeah the conversation around this
show has been nothing short of an
enjoyment
all right guys um leave a like if you're
here
i would appreciate that or leave a
dislike if you're one of those people
also subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our reaction for the next episode lord
of the rings is up here on this channel
as always following throughout your
watch long sync up with the time code
meaning your own copy
available at our super sexy rejects
patreon page over there we cover several
shows with the same tier you get options
for reaction heights and watch long's
included for several shows i think i
said that right and the team of prepper
thanks for helping us edit down these
highlights all right guys let's see
let's see if there's a good one it's the
game this game you play lord of the
rings now let's see
[Music]
[Music]
it's like a whole bunch of con shoes
or backstage at a haunted house
[Applause]
oh wow
that's pretty evil
what is this place
wow
the westernmost of all mortal realms
the island kingdom
of numenor
numenor
[Music]
i don't know if anybody's pointed this
out yet but uh some of the visuals and
production design are really striking
and beautiful newman order began to turn
away our ships in time they broke off
all contact why
we may be about to find out you would
not want to be lost here without an
escort
you filthy elf
something feels very roman about this
whole thing it is because of the elves
that you were given this island
surely you can spare a few planks and
rudder
don't forget your history
they paid for this aisle
with the blood of their kin what the elf
means then if blood be the price of
passage i will pay it
one way or another i will depart
you need to take a master class on
negotiations collagera
give and take
three days
and the elf is to be restricted to
palestine i will not be made a prisoner
i would soon a kneecap a stallion then
seek to imprison the mighty commander of
the northern army
my gratitude
he just stole your wallet
i have been searching for my piece for
longer than you know
please
for both our sakes let me keep it
[Music]
get a sharp eye how did he take a
a big-ass blade like that
editing i knew he did but i was like
he goes high your eye goes up to the
shoulder
you just forget all about the rest of
your body
[Music]
oh easter egg
becomes more than just
protectors
oh yeah
save the crew moment
[Applause]
he's like a more sexy tony revelry
[Laughter]
and a little bit of luke wilson in there
[Music]
there you are
very my boy
[Laughter]
that's that's actually funny are you
an elf friend
i'm a loyal servant of numenor you
dodged the question
it was the sea that put her in my path
and the sea is always right
given the circumstances i did only what
i believed to be most prudent then i
shall have to ask you to perform
cers
[Music]
he can't kill galadriel
bring me the head
[Music]
do i sense an alec over here
please
south
black man put in chains
and countries squabbling over the
ethics of their
and
origins
oh
rip the whole stinking tree down we
shall go around try it out
and i will make a mess at your back
that's some gnarly makeup
it has earned its place in these lands
you've just earned your company
a water ration surely you thirst
come on man
chug chug chug
these works look great
[Applause]
that will cut the dog
i love that elf man the one who just
died is about very attached to
spend so much time bonding
over the course of three episodes i
informed him last time that was a dog
i'm afraid the queen has charged me with
saying to me that you caused no further
disturbance i got cut off your head
anywhere is better than here where i'm
hated by all who see me
so call to your guards
or get out of my way
yeah if you want to be undercover just
cover your ears
it is still taught in our hall of law
still carved on statues throughout the
city if you look closely enough your
hall of law how far is that
quarter day's right did you say ride
i'm a guest on your island and i haven't
shown you the faintest bit of gratitude
next few rounds on me
[Applause]
let's get some songs
oh look where his hand is lingering
keep watching his hand
and he took it
why not
ouch
he wants a new start because he's john
wick
[Music]
[Music]
you didn't say the hall of law was
assembled by elros himself
you knew elros an uncommon spirit
but i was always closer with his brother
remarkable that's a damn good accurate
painting
he drew this
to recall the tower's location
wait a moment
i must be blind
this is no sigil it's part of the map
we'll make it to the grove
how i stayed the front of the caravan
and we got nori
look once that girl puts her head to
something nothing can stop her that's
part of the problem
you lay one paw on that book an old
saddle could use your height to make his
next patch of painting you got a better
idea
what since it's sticking your neck out
for him any more than you already have
there's headsets poppy and there's
hearts there's common sense and nonsense
some of mine rather throw some star
shirts out of that book instead
and you're gonna help me or would you
rather i let slip to malva it was you
put fireweed in her toe cream i'll keep
watch
don't you lose her samwise poppy well
they said that uh silver's father's name
um
was it like admirer of the stars or
something yeah
so another of his line so it's
definitely gandalf
[Laughter]
you are not subtle
how much have you got left
[Music]
just a little left
just tell them i'm almost ready right no
i mean left yes no
i'll tell him right now go straight now
dearest
lindsey proud fellow
taken by landslide one rainy winter day
we wait for you jesus
so they needed to create like a shire
[Music]
yikes dude
[Music]
[Music]
it's a palrog you have lied
you've stolen
brought a dangerous outsider into our
midst and she lied
our way has kept us alive a thousand
years
our laws are clear
any half foot that breaks them
is to be
de-caravanned
oh my god
miss brandyfoot is young
but as much hair still to grow on her
toes as sense between her ears
tomorrow we depart as planned at the
back of the caravan at the back at the
back
get the man to help out
yeah just have him carry her dad
that's all right i was thinking i might
defer
defer
just for a season perhaps
there is nothing for us on our western
shores
the past is dead
we either move forward or we die with it
and do you think it was easy convincing
the sail master you were up to the task
i never asked you to do that yes you did
when you got into a scrap with the
queen's guard they started all got
thrown out of your horse train that
wasn't my fault actually it feels right
that one was i wasn't talking to you
damn silver was a rebel
in nine days time
when the sea trial begins and that [ __ ]
launches you will be on it
i made apprentice
i've been accepted to the builders
killed
hmm
i thought that you'll never reconsidered
the steel door convinced me to reapply
convinced you
he's a ghost he's already gone
off to the western shores
a man bearing that mark
united the scattered tribes of the
southlands under one banner against the
evil and now seeks to claim their lands
your lands hell brand
he's got the bad dude
for you are him
huh it kinda reminds me of a character
from those
movies who it was
airy harry potter
it was his ancestor who swore a blood
oath to morgoth
i am not the hero you seek
but it was my family
that lost the war and it was mine who
started it
ours was no chance meeting nor any of
the words men used to speak of the
forces they lacked the conviction to
name even the reason he
decides to not fight is similar to
aragorn
come with me to middle earth and
together we will redeem both our
bloodlines you're stuck on this island
that is all about to change
you're just here father
the moment we feared
the elf has arrived
where are you live tonight
gonna have to start giving all sorts of
land back to the elves man it's gonna
topple everything
is it doing it he's doing it
friend
this is how we keep up with the others
all of us
he helps us and
we help him
hit both cards to him
[Music]
wow
[Music]
oh ouch
[Music]
oh
[Music]
smart
burn
[Music]
wowie
looks like a
sonic the hedgehog
ugly sonic's getting work
yikes
tame it
earn its respect i'm pretty sure that's
not happening
this also kind of looks like the
american werewolf
[Music]
damn this dude's just flying today
and just as deadly with a twig as
anything else
ouch
[Music]
oh
after all that
[Music]
all right
well
chuckles mcgee
[Laughter]
you know some some things just work
little moments come together and i'm
like ah it's fun or clever or i wasn't
expecting that and then those things get
a chuckle from me
editors
keep every time john chuckled
we're gonna play we should have a head
count
sure sure yeah
john john smile
yeah i'll have a little count a little
counter yeah that's just one of the ways
i react to stuff
at times i don't understand i'm like you
don't have to understand although if
it's a problem i'll stop doing it i
guess
i'll focus in and be very self-aware
enough not to do it i don't understand
what's funny or amusing about
it's not always that it's funny
sometimes it's clever and and sometimes
those clever moments stand out because
this is a show filled with
beauty and filled with like a lot of
clear craftsmanship and skill sometimes
it's during really dark moments that's
when i'm like what i don't know yeah
this is every now and then i get it
will still strike me with something
clever or or a tonal twist i wasn't
expecting or something and that'll just
i don't know
because then i'm like nice nice one nice
one people behind the camera or whatever
it happens whatever context that i'm
clever chuckling in clever chuckling
i guess that's what i would boil it down
to i mean you know it's not a
there's no uniform description for it it
happens under a lot of different
circumstances but yes if i'm if i
chuckle during a moment that isn't
clearly a joke moment it's usually oh
there's like a weird little detail that
you know called me toward the movie
magic or called me toward
you know just like some neat twist that
i wasn't expecting behind the camera
it's best i could describe that can give
me an example
from this episode yeah
i don't remember i don't log them
they're natural enough to me that i
you've noticed them more uh directly
than i have i'm not challenging you to
anything i'm literally just asking
um
okay i'll
i'll think of one while we go
wrong
boom
point
[Laughter]
you don't have a concrete example for a
thing you weren't doing consciously like
any good relationship fight logical
rings around you sir name one time
i'll go back through the rear this but
the but here's the thing is we have the
footage so i'll go back and review the
footage and then i'll get back to you
with all that i'll sync it up and i'll
do the watch
here's
i already forgot about this conversation
no i have 16 distinct moments
that was clever because of this and i
thought that was neat because of that
i'll stop caring about this conversation
in like five seconds
that's the difference between you and me
is because yeah then i'll take that home
and be like oh no i gotta i kind of
analyze this for myself and figure it
out i don't care enough about this [ __ ]
yeah
yeah that's fine
so what do you what'd you think i
thought take it away
i thought this was these i don't know
maybe i maybe i have those clever laughs
because of the odd
experience this has been so far because
there's stuff i really like about the
show and let me interrupt too
you don't have to explain it i'm just
teasing you i don't know how to explain
anything to me like no but i i'm using
it as a segue now i'm using it as a
segue because i some shows and certain
things make me do that more than others
and this show has an interesting blend
because i'm inclined to
want to meet the show halfway you know
i'm always rooting for a good lord of
the rings universe anything despite
trepidations i wanted the hobbit movies
to be
unanimously agreeable um and this has
you know a lot of things i appreciate
and it does have moments of warmth or
intimacy that draw me in
um but it is
to me right now just here in this moment
and maybe with more consideration i'll
feel different but you know it feels
like it's a slow unfolding and it's sort
of like it always feels like it's
ramping up towards something big and and
some kind of
i always feel like um it's like a song
that that never breaks into some kind of
cathartic chorus quite
where it's like okay i'm interested in
everybody and
i kind of
i almost feel it's
you could have uh i could spend more
time
and cut between less things per episode
because i just want to see the life
between these you commented when the one
elf died uh during the fight and that's
clearly supposed to be an impactful
emotional moment and i
was in that moment but i wasn't like
caught up and emotionally wrenched
because yeah like i liked those three
actors together and i liked the actor
who you know had just you know
bit it but
you know we don't get the
time spent in this situation beyond okay
here's what it's like getting into the
slave camp now here's what it's like
just doing the activity and now we gotta
you know figure out a way out of it and
now here's a big confrontation you know
i feel like if we could spend a little
more time
uh that would help uh but yeah like i'm
interested in everything it's just not
yet got that like
the pace is moving and everything's kind
of locking together and complimenting
each other it just feels like we're
checking in on different points of a big
wide map
are you uh okay
are you enjoying it
yes
yeah i'm not loving it yet there's a lot
of stuff i enjoy admire and appreciate
there's stuff i do want more of or you
know want to become more substantial
it's not perfect i don't love it yet but
there's a lot i really like about it
okay
i'm happy for you
i mean you're laughing your [ __ ] ass
off because of the fact of how much you
enjoy this [ __ ] that's right i'm just
like give me more this is absolutely
perfect to give it to me
i just yeah that's my shooting grin
[Music]
when i love something
i just only laugh
uh
well no i mean
hey there's a lot of people who are
really enjoying this show
i'm really happy for you guys
i gotta say it's like a two out of three
for me
i'm just i like i like the second
episode much more
than the first
and then this was right back to the
first episode for me okay and uh in all
regards oh
um
i don't care that i'm a little sleep
deprived i've enjoyed many many many
things on this channel very sleep
deprived there's nothing to do with it
as a matter of fact
i'm still pretty awake
and uh
i looked at every second of this screen
i give my focus
so if you're someone who i i really
don't know how accurate this is to token
lore
incredibly from what i've read and i
don't care
if it is or is it i really don't yeah
i
can't stomach the thought
go on
i mean you're you're just a lot more
forgiving than me
and
more patient
sure i've been on set
um
so i try to i'm trying to be
compassionate here
but i'm also gonna be really honest
sure i've been on set uh
for uh
i was reminded the reason the back girl
cancellation upset me so much was
because of my experience that i actually
had on set recently as po
after the batgirl experience
is that
just it was a reminder that like wow to
shoot just a few seconds of a fill of a
show or a film or something
like with a with a full long crew and i
can imagine it's it's it's way harder
for this show than what i got to be
privy to for a pretty decent sized show
um
it can take like 20 to 30 minutes on
average just to capture a few seconds
sometimes it takes up to an hour i can
imagine on this show with the level of
thought
that and and production
that it must have taken forever to shoot
an episode like
countless people these people credited
these are all these people working so
hard
and it takes so long to put one of these
together it's a lot of labor
so it sucks when i'm like you know what
though the i think the writing of this
show for the most part is not good
and that's why script is so important
because you're gonna get like all these
people together to bring the script to
life
and if the script's not good
man that could be uh that could be
really
boring and usually like i feel like it's
a waste of time for a lot of people so
so you can sit here and i appreciate
your patience i i do like i appreciate
that i wish i had that mentality
of you could sit here and go you know
after three hours i'm not loving this
but you know i'm liking bits and pieces
and i'm still waiting i'm still getting
like no no for me
three hours
i should love something about this by
now that's right and i really don't i
just don't and uh
yeah you can't
you can't deny the fact that
that's like one lord of the rings movie
right there in three hours that's no
it's one hobbit movie and after three
hours of that i don't
and and the amount of cutting around the
characters i just find myself slowly
slumping and
just trying to care and getting bored
i'm just really bored
i was very bored this episode
other than the occasional cool the one
thing this show has surprised me on
is the violence is they kind of push the
violence a little more than i expected
them to
which is cool
always go for a little bit of juicy
violence
uh i did notice that the one per two
people we did not check in one were the
two i
enjoyed the most there's nothing
yeah at all in this episode two uh two i
like like i like um
nari i i like her
and uh there are pleasantries it's
kind of predictable how played out
and
this guy
from whatever southland is
is he from the token universe is he is
here
because it's just sounds seems like
aragorn on repeat
it's almost exactly
in a lot of ways aragorn on repeat just
far less compelling and way more cliche
yeah it's weird how this has had so much
time to do what it's doing and yet it
doesn't feel like it's really taking its
time but it doesn't also feel like it's
getting that much done in the amount of
time
and there's like you look at those
original lord of the rings movies and i
mean you know everyone's gonna keep
harping that but it's true like with
less time they manage to give you
the right amount of scenes that allow
the characters to bond you to bond with
them you to care
and you to get invested in all these
different things so that it feels like a
big living world rather than like oh oh
yeah that's right there's this character
and they're doing that and and there's
all these it's weird they have all these
guideposts and things to foreshadow and
i feel like that
that does kind of kneecap them in a way
because it's painting it's it feels like
it could easily paint itself into a
corner of you just being the the same
it's like the fantastic beasts
movies have sort of fallen into this
trap of like i don't know we gotta have
a new voldemort and a new kind of
voldemorty thing to do and we gotta kind
of force this new thing to be the thing
everybody knows
and i'm afraid that that's essentially
what's gonna happen here
because i don't know you're not wrong
it's weird like i don't disagree with
much that you're saying and my biggest
worry i was surrounding the entire show
was like great awesome i know amazon can
make a show that looks good
but uh the scripts have to be great and
no they're not great like there are
moments of dialogue that i find pleasant
or whatever but yeah like brass tacks
it's not great right now and it's
unfortunate to have house of the dragon
right across the street because they
excel like if they just if i don't want
to necessarily say that lord of the
rings needs to just be game of thrones
far from that but they could learn a
thing or two
from how they choose to yeah
complement the plot with actual
character tones and really show the sort
of
complexity of actually living in this
world i feel like the magic of bringing
tolkien to life is that we get to live
in the world rather than yeah feeling
like
we're just doing a bunch of plot beats
and stuff and kind of pointing and going
oh yeah sauron he's coming
he'll be here i think it
i think it uh its focus
as as much as they try to simplify a
focus which is
the rise of sauron and how these
people have come together
will come together to defeat the common
enemy to fight him to cut off his
cut the ring off his finger and put his
finger off and then a sealed or not
throw it into the
flames
of mordor uh yeah i
sure like i can i can find that linear
path but it's it really
feels like it lacks a pulse it feels
like it it lacks stakes surprisingly it
feels like it
it's not exciting it's it's not uh the
stakes don't feel real because even like
the orc camp feels really detached from
everything
yes the org camp does feel detached from
everything and they and the characters
are
um
they don't give them much life
the hard foots the most you get of life
in this episode is the harford's having
their memorial thing
i felt like nori's just repeated the
same monologues you know just like uh
it's it's very it's like i feel like you
kind of just said a lot of the same
things you said in the last episode when
i really liked you in the last episode
i get it
it's out in the open about your secret
giant so then you have
got to repeat some of the [ __ ] now to
your mom and stuff like i understand
um
and yeah they're they're doing a lot of
world building but i'm like for christ's
sake for three episodes of
of like nothing felt more human more
connective than during being
being hurt by elrond for not checking in
on him like that
connected
yeah
or a mother protecting her son from an
orc invading their home like
that that that that hits and then here
i'm i'm just
i'm just like
watching people display information to
me well yeah and there's also i think i
i've come to start associating this
version of lord of the rings with the
big wide shot that never compensates
with doing a pov then we enter numenor
like the the storied city of newman or
and we mostly
you know like there's great production
value there that you can't appreciate
but they don't it's like when you're in
lord of the rings what's so great about
having the hobbits at the center is they
do give you that ground level
perspective to be like wow this is a
truly extraordinary array
of
places and circumstances and i feel like
we get too many bird's-eye views and not
enough ground level views on these
things
and that
is both in a construction way but also
definitely in a character kind of
way it's like it's so it's like yeah
with nori this episode pretty much all
we developed was oh yeah everybody finds
out about the giant and uh i guess
that's gonna be fine and we're gonna
keep them
and and now we're moving on yeah guy
gets pulled into this orc camp and then
he stages a 300 fight
and i i enjoy galadriel
um
in the first episode
even though i thought that episode was
like
uh
i i did say like i i really enjoyed what
the
what the actress is doing
and then here i'm like okay now you just
seem
i'm just a little bit like come on guys
and i know i'm not the voice of
the mature or i don't i don't know what
the hell the majority honestly i don't
know what the majority is with the show
i i don't i don't know what the majority
is it seems hard to pin a majority
because there's everything yeah i i know
i'm i'm part of a certain camp that is
not the
skrull culture camp
i'm just part of the camp that's like
honestly i think the show is just pretty
disappointing in a lot of ways and kind
of boring and it should be more i think
it's i think it
it's got to be i just don't care about a
lot of these
the things that are happening i really
thought we were on our upswing after the
second episode for me i thought we were
i'm sure and uh i could be
in this i could be the mine like i'm
watching this before
we're watching this before any opinions
have been released yet
so
for all we know i could i could turn on
social media and be like wow everyone
thought this was the best one
whoopsie
but
i'll be honest with you this was this
was like this did nothing for it just it
just got more new more characters
more information
and and it's it's lacking this this very
strong directional
it's like think about this
i mean if you do think about like lord
of the rings i saw some people who who
went like i you know i watched the
hobbit trilogy before going into this
and i gotta say this is better
and okay
that's that's that's cool if if that is
the thing you're just gonna compare it
to sure
do i want to commit
to watching a show
which is going to be longer than the
hobbit trilogy
it's
if you look at like lord of the rings
it's something like pretty simple to
latch on to a character
gets a ring and is now thrusted onto a
life or death adventure where they're
going to un cover information as they go
and the ensemble grows the more
information they uncover yeah it's not
enough fellowship until like two-thirds
of the movie
in and you're not cutting to a million
things by that point yeah and then here
we're just cutting around to a bunch and
they keep treating it
with this like stoic gravitas
and that it's the like the most life
impending doom
stakes in the world
when
i i weirdly feel like it's just not that
well it's not as
if you're gonna go stoic and heavy yeah
gravitas all the time you have to back
it up with some depth and
uh some
i don't know real themes not that they
don't have themes but like you gotta be
able to really put the themes in there
and to really make the characters feel
vital so that
that gravitas attaches itself to the
[ __ ] that you care about and if you're
detached from it then yeah the gravitas
is just gonna feel like a filter and
it's gonna feel like it's trying to make
up the lost ground of what the writing
isn't actually doing
and uh
it feels masturbatory in its poetic way
well it does feel a bit
style over sub it's like it's like
watching shakespeare
from somebody who you can tell has
practiced the lines but doesn't like
fully
understand the breadth of how
shakespearean language works at times i
feel like i'm watching like a cosplayer
actors in a museum it's like watching a
play that isn't that's like has
impressive bits and pieces but isn't
coalescing into just the transport of
play experience no
and uh
i think this ought to be it should
absolutely ought to be i mean if again
like
for whatever enjoyment i can get from
this if you want to come right down to
it like yeah this for the most expensive
show of all time based on one of the
most beloved pieces of fiction that has
inspired so much
the the writing has to be great the
writing should be great so my logic
brain is pretty much with you across all
of this you don't have to agree with me
no but it's funny because i i wonder
what that critical element is because i
find this more pleasant to watch and i
am i enjoy my time checking in with this
world but logically like yeah
i'm not
getting what i was rooting for
yet and even though like galadriel in
this episode
there for me there were little glimmers
where i was like oh there's like a
mischief in your eye
and it looks like oh maybe there's some
there is some joy under there for
certain things and and good god i wish
we would maybe hone in on those or get a
character
i didn't i i think it's
it's tone and pacing is is seriously
kind of all over the place yeah it is
like when she was riding that horse
yes i was like what the hell is
happening right now this this this
individual sequence is gorgeous and and
ethereal but also it's not motivated
well enough by everything around it
it's like it's like
what i haven't seen sucker punch
but i imagined
i'm saying instead of instead of
what i've heard about sucker punch
instead of
you know zack snyder being like [ __ ]
look how cool i am it's like
[ __ ] look how poetic i
this am [ __ ] of mine is
that's what i imagine i'm watching here
it looks cool but it's not just cool
it's all so important
yes
um
and uh
it feels desperate to capture a sense of
wonder without it authentically getting
there and that's one of my biggest
issues with it yeah it makes me sad in
that way
to zoom out from it because
i mean this is a big opportunity for all
involved the second episode leaned so
much more into horror yeah it was kind
of like okay we're leaning in the horror
it was kind of a consistent thing
throughout it
and there was a sort of like dark mood
it's my man by gohna and then here they
were like
all right we're going to go to
that was that
what becomes gondor
oh is that the lineage of
like
or just before gondor i forget yeah
who the [ __ ] cares all right so
if you've made it to this point in the
video i think you're inclined to forgive
us lately meet the queen i'm like oh
here we go another stoic ass character
and i was like okay cool maybe we'll see
behind closed doors and we'll get like a
real sense for who this person is though
but but no not yet no
just another stoic
character burdened with perp everyone's
burdened with purpose
everything is just so like actually that
is a thought that went off in my head as
i i'm burdened with glorious perfect
i actually had i was like i'm not gonna
say it because i was like i know i was a
sarcastic [ __ ] in the first episode
so you know what i'm just gonna
sit back a little bit more and just
really try to take this in and
nope not not clicking for me
yeah
yeah
this is kind of like my hobbit
experience
it was enjoyed the desolation of smock
yeah well now that's now that's the
thing is i'm like okay because right now
this is kind of
it started out you know naturally kind
of above the hobbit but it's their
balance they're beginning to balance out
because while i find certain aspects of
this more pleasing than the hobbit it's
also like
that i think the hobbit might have more
intermittent moments that actually come
together but i don't know
we'll see i'm always rooting for it to
get to get
to rise to this occasion but
yeah
and i'm fascinated to see what everybody
thinks strong out the gate this should
have been no way
like 100
we're three hours in and i'm like
come on guys
no the the only thing again like it was
like they you have everything and this
is what i what i was dreading the whole
time is you're not
you know far be it from me to tell you
how to choose show runners and how to
choose writers but so far
and three episodes in yeah like this is
eight episode series
so you know we're a substantial way in
and yeah that's not heartening to me and
that makes me actually sad because again
like this is what i was dreading and
it's funny to watch again game of
thrones come back and in the same amount
of episodes less slightly more time
everyone seems really on board with that
because they managed to take
the sort of hobbit movies to the first
several game of thrones seasons lord of
the rings that became the later parts of
game of thrones and actually redeem that
and actually deliver on like oh wait
this is actually like just as intriguing
but just as personal but just as blah
blah blah else
and i mean you know
it's possible it can be done and it
doesn't feel like
like i don't know it doesn't feel like
they are as focused on getting into the
nitty-gritty of what you necessitate by
spending yeah eight
hours and change in this world you know
and like almost a billion dollars and
almost a billion dollars and all the
resource and that's the scary thing is
part of me is like i feel like the most
expensive show with uh moniker is almost
a curse especially if that's what you're
known for right out the gate because
then it's like well if this isn't just
perfect then
all bets are off i mean like not to say
it couldn't get to a second season but
part of me is like well this isn't great
or doesn't get great for
a good amount of time
then i mean is this going to tank i
don't know how much to believe the
people who say like there's a lot of
amazon prime's future is tied up in lord
of the rings and i'm like well
while i don't expect them to crumble if
this doesn't do well at the same time
like i bet this would have an impact if
it doesn't overall net do well because i
mean this seems like
a risk even though lord of the rings is
beloved and in some ways surefire this
is absolutely a risk
they're taking
it seems like more stuff hangs on this
than just well it's just not as that
interesting too
even in the grand scheme of things we're
just going backwards
yeah it's like the hobbit went
um
you know they wanted to tie it into lord
of the rings what happened right before
lord of the rings with bilbo okay now
let's go even further back
well that's what they put i'm like you
keep building to this [ __ ] sauron
business
well that's the pro that's that is a
problem if every freaking star wars
property which already has its own
terrible case of repetition
kept building to who
darth vader would come to resort
and let's flesh out more details about
that situation and and i'd rather be
like this thing i was sorry and that's
the pro that's to me a lot of what the
hobbit movies missed was in doing that
and being like no no no like we got to
directly tie this into the lord of the
rings and really make it like a huge
piece of that puzzle
it it sucks the thing out of the hobbit
that would have made it a good idea in
the first place which is its own story
and yeah it relates down the line but
it's not really about that and i feel
like this could have chosen to do that
again like
and i promise every episode i won't do
this but you look at house of the dragon
and you're like well you know we're just
going back in time and we know a certain
amount of things are gonna happen and
this could easily become
the same shape again just like to me the
fantastic beasts movies have started to
do or it's like okay we're going back in
time we're going to see a different part
of the world but ah now we kind of got
to do the same structure
and it's like i feel like you can go
back in a world as rich as this into a
middle period and an explorer but this
it doesn't seem
i feel like this should have been a show
arguably where the plot and the big you
know sauron machinations like i wouldn't
really want to even hear about like
sauron
every episode until like season three
out of five or something you know or
yeah i'm like this is gonna be five
seasons cause yeah right now it does
feel like you got your checklist of
characters who are
regardless of you know
context and and race and gender swapping
or whatever you've got your archetypical
lord of the rings we recognize
characters and dynamics
and uh
and yeah
i'm gonna start checking twitter john i
know i'm sorry um
this has been
weirdly the
one of the more unfun
discourses surrounding the show because
because the thing too is everyone's like
got a big kind of extreme feeling and
nobody seems unified like it would be
simpler if it was just like
you know
the the the people who want to hate it
and then the rest of us
but uh nah i mean they're i'm fascinated
because each time ever like some people
really love it and i'm like
i feel more positive towards this
obviously than you do but at the same
time like i want to see what you what
what you see
because i don't quite see that and there
are people who like i hate this and it
sucks and i'm like well i don't quite
see that but i
get
most places you're coming from sans you
know a small percentage of
arguments we've already talked to
so
[Music]
can't wait to go on twitter this friday
and every friday for the next five weeks
don't worry people will hate it and
people will love it and then there's the
e23 and then
house and and then you know people just
we'll move on
sure we move on in two days
that's that thing you get to see the in
the episode the last jedi and then you
got a few years old
yeah there you go put something like
this i don't know
i don't know
[Music]
all right
yes to a patriots day
daniel gallacher
we looked your name up on urban
dictionary that way john does not make
another pharmacy scottish joke oh
daniel is the name given to many
pharmacists
see it's in the definition you're on the
right path but one of the most popular
things daniels are known for
are being scottish
what do you know it's in your blood
kind and sensitive people who put
themselves in harm's way just to help
and protect people who are closest to
them just like at the pharmacy that's
what pharmacists constantly like when
the pan endemic was at its peak he was
going in and still helping people
exposed to people
masculist when he was told to wear a
mask but he thought it's not real risk
if he has a mask on
just saying do you don't see batman with
a face protect mask do you no or hockey
pads
daniels are also people who are willing
to give out advice when they feel
necessary even if they aren't asked for
it that's true he's constantly imposing
us telling us what to do with the
channel
i don't really want to go into unboxing
videos that much thank you daniel
um daniels are also shy and can take a
while to get to open up oh that's true
yeah it was like pulling teeth one time
literally was
and still wouldn't talk very shy about
that accent but once they do they can be
great friends who can be approached to
for any reason and without judgment yes
scottish people man they're accepting
people that's what we like to hear
that's true and pharmacists not supposed
to judge you you're supposed to you know
like patient doctor confidentiality i
mean according to urban dictionary what
they say is wow daniel is so helpful and
kind he just knew what to say this is
what they usually say about daniels
and you know what i got a test for the
longest time i've known daniel gallacher
yeah
yeah
he is helpful and kind he always knows
what to say
say something dan
and like remember when i was constipated
and daniel prescribed me some pills he
did to make me unconstipated yeah that
worked and then i had to really weak off
the channel because you were so nice
it was hard to sit down here for a
reaction to watch a movie the exact
opposite scenario i can't just keep
pausing the movie to go to the bathroom
yeah it was like casper's just every
time you eat something just fall right
out the bottom and then we try one time
where i was just [ __ ] my pants while
we were watching a movie that's when we
were watching rr yeah yeah yeah
our reaction too long and we can't sit
here for that long while i'm pooping
yeah so i'm just getting away we
shouldn't have miked your seat you know
i think that was the big mistake with
the road mic yeah with the
backup lav mic yeah
yeah yeah with too many microphones
around the base of your chair in that
reaction i think that's when we learned
we shouldn't do that
but uh hey you stayed regular and uh
you're looking felt and that's all
thanks to damn well thanks daniel
because he recommends clean doesn't
prescribes me stuff without
a doctor's prescription that's right he
abuses his position of power
give people medications they don't
necessarily good pharmacist
love you buddy
[Music]